hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live in 12 Stunden sollte die viertägige
Feuerpause zwischen Israel und der Hamas
eigentlich enden aber jetzt am Abend vor
unserer Sendung dann die Meldung sie
soll um zwei Tage verlängert werden
israel wolle über den heutigen Abend
hinaus 50 weitere Geiseln freibekommen
sagte der israelische Regierungssprecher
Levi hoffnung für alle seit zwei Monaten
um das Leben ihrer Liebsten bangen und
Hoffnung auch für Zivilisten in Gaza
solange die Waffen schweigen haben sie
einen kurzen Moment um sich mit dem
Nötigsten einzudecken und auch nach
ihren liebsten Menschen zu sehen eine
Feuer Pause heißt auch sie kann
militärisch genutzt werden und was das
bringt wem das mehr bringt das ist heute
bei uns Thema wie die Feuerpause der
Herr Mass nützt das wollen wir
diskutieren mit euch gerne die Einladung
dass ihr mit kommentiert direkt im
Stream oder Fragen stellt auch gerne per
Mail wo ihr unterwegs seid und ich
versuche so viele wie möglich davon hier
unseren Experten zu stellen denn wir
haben uns eingeladen jetzt zuerst
Hendrik Remmel er ist militäranalyst am
German Institute for defense and
strategy studies einer Denkfabrik der
Bundeswehr außerdem hat er mehrere Jahre
Erfahrung als kampftruppenoffizier der
Bundeswehr und ist jetzt hier bei uns
hallo schönen guten Tag Herr
Remmel schönen guten Abend hallo herrel
wir haben es eben gerade schon
angesprochen die Feuerpause das ist eine
Meldung von heute also um zwei Tage
verlängert die Kampfpause ihre
Einschätzung nach wie kam es jetzt zu
dieser Entscheidung und auch welche
Taktik steckt
dahinter grundsätzlich können sich die
israelischen Streitkräfte und die
israelische Regierung sich schlicht und
ergreifend erlauben diese Feuerpause
diese Waffenruhe um zwei Tage
auszudehnen ähm wenn in Aussicht steht
dass sie mehrere Geiseln in einem
Austausch mit äh
Gefangenen Palästinensern sicherstellen
können das liegt daran dass die
israelischen Streitkräfte in den
vergangenen zwei Wochen die operative
Kontrolle über den nördlichen
gaserastreifen erlangt haben und
letztenendes aufgrund dieser Kontrolle
relativ klar absehen können welche
militärischen Vor oder Nachteile sich
aus einer solchen Feuerpause ergeben und
dadurch nehmen sie natürlich ein Stück
weit auch den internationalen
Druck aus dieser kompletten
Gefechtssituation weil natürlich auch
neben der Befreiung bzw dem Austausch
von Gefangenen und Geiseln
die Versorgung der notleiden
zivilevölkerung im nördlichen Teil des
gaserstreifens ermöglicht werden kann
die Geiseln die nach Hause kommen sollen
nach eben zwei Monaten auch heute
konnten wieder welche befreit werden wir
schauen mal auf einen Rückblick auf
diesen Tag ein Beitrag von L
walpot Freude gestern im kibut quaasa
sie feiern die Rückkehr von Geiseln aus
ihrer Gemeinde darunter die vierjährige
us statsbürgerinigel edan ihr Großvater
einer der ersten der sie sehen
durfte es war unglaublich ich konnte es
nicht fassen ich bin einfach nur
erleichtert aber es gibt andere die noch
nicht zurückgekehrt sind ich will dass
auch sie
heimkommen 51 Tage war die kleine avigil
in den Händen von Hamas Terroristen die
beim Überfall am 7 Oktober erst ihre
Mutter dann ihren Vater erschossen der
sich schützend über sie legte dann wurde
afigil nach Gaza verschleppt wie viele
andere auch mehr als 180 Geiseln sind
noch in der Hand der Hamas und auch
heute warten die israelischen Familien
wieder auf die gute
Nachricht die Feuerpause sollte
ausgeweitet werden wir wollen dass alle
nach Hause kommen was auch immer dafür
verlangt
wird nach einigen Verzögerungen hieß es
am Abend weitere elf Geiseln neun Kinder
und zwei Frauen werden heute
freigelassen und noch eine gute
Nachricht meldeten die Vermittler aus
Qatar die Feuerpause wird um zwei Tage
verlängert Zeit um mehr Geiseln
freizulassen Zeit auch um mehr
Hilfslieferungen für die
Zivilbevölkerung in den Gasastreifen zu
bringen in hanunis nutzten tausende die
Gelegenheit um Treibstoff kochgas und
Lebensmittel zu besorgen die
Warteschlangen sind
lang wir können nur noch einmal am Tag
Tee trinken weil kein Gas da ist die
Kinder gehen hungrig zu Bett es gibt
kaum Brot vorerst hält die Feuerpause
mit ihr auch die Hoffnung auf beiden
Seiten israel will über diese Feuerpause
von Tag zu Tag entscheiden haben sie ja
auch heute gemacht Hamas war da gleich
für eine mehrtägige Feuerpause die eben
noch länger dauert welche Strategie
steckt
dahinter ja die israelischen
Streitkräfte versuchen natürlich ihr
weiteres Vorgehen ihr Kalkül in dieser
Waffenruhe so unberechenbar wie möglich
zu halten je mehr Aussicht und je mehr
zeitlicher vollauf die Hamas auf eben
diese waffenpausen hat in einem
zeitlichen Zusammenhang destu bessere
planerische Grundlagen haben Sie
natürlich auch die israelischen
Streitkräfte haben diese Bedürftigkeit
an planerischer Grundlage nicht
ihre Einheiten ihre Verbände stehen in
den Ausgangspositionen
mit denen sie unmittelbar die
gefechtshandlung weiter fortsetzen
können und deswegen versucht natürlich
Israel in diesem rational sich so
unberechenbar wie möglich zu halten und
gleichzeitig diesen Balanceakt zu wagen
den Gefangenen Austausch zu gehen und
kommen wir auch jetzt direkt mal zu dem
Titel unseres Streams wie die Feuerpause
der Hamas nützt können Sie uns sagen wem
nutzt diese Feuerpause eben wie und
warum also zu allererst nutz diese
Feuerpause der
Zivilbevölkerung weil sie in der Lage
ist ihre humanitäre Notsituation
zumindest ein bisschen zu lindern sie
nutzt auch den Gefangenen Palästinensern
und den Gefangenen Geiseln
Israels für die Hamas ergibt sich nur
ein bedingter Nutzen aus dieser
Feuerpause weil natürlich Israel
weiterhin Aufklärung betreibt es gibt
die Vereinbarung dass keine Drohnen über
dem Gasastreifen fliegen aber Israel hat
natürlich auch andere Aufklärungsmittel
sie hat nachrichtendienstliche
Aufklärungsmittel am Boden sie hat
Flugzeuge hochfliegende Flugzeuge die
Aufklärung betreiben und sie hat
satellitenauklärung das heißt eine
wirkliche Regeneration der Kräfte oder
eine Restrukturierung wird der Hamas
durch auch schwer fallen vor allem weil
in den letzten Wochen signifikante
sogenannte command and control
Strukturen also führungseinrichtung der
heramas getroffen worden sind das
erschwert natürlich die
Führungsfähigkeit der hammerskräfte und
in wenigen Tagen können Sie sich in so
einem begrenzten Raum ind dem sie auch
keinen Raum Preis geben können oder
regenerieren können sich nicht wieder
neu konstituieren das heißt die ähm der
der der militärische Nutzen der Hamas äh
für diese Feuerpause ist eher gering ähm
primär nutzt ist der Hamas natürlich
weil ein gewisser Druck auf die
Hamas genommen wird weil die
Zivilbevölkerung besser versorgt wird
das gleiche gilt auch für Israel israel
hat allerdings keinen signifikanten
nutzen aber auch keinen signifikanten
Nachteil von dieser Feuerpause und das
ist auch das rational warum sich dieses
handlungsfenster verhandlungsfenster für
die Geiselbefreiung bzw den Austausch
von Geiseln und Gefangenen aufgetan hat
wir gehen da gleich noch mehr ins Detail
und haben vor allem dann auch Zeit für
eure Fragen sie sind gleich noch mal bei
uns hend militäranalyst also gleich für
eure Fragen hier noch mal bei uns im
Stream wir wollen jetzt aber noch mal
ganz genau auf die Einzelschicksale auch
eingehen denn klar hinter jedem Namen
einer Geisel oder eines Toten in diesem
furchtbaren Krieg steht die Geschichte
einer ganzen Familie die seit zwei
Monaten bald eben bangt und trauert z.B
eine Geschichte wie von Thomas hent wir
sehen ih hier im Bild und seiner
neunjährigen Tochter Emily erst sagte
man ihrem Vater emels Vater Emily sei am
7.10 von der Hamas getötet worden dann
hieß es aber sie sei als Geisel
verschleppt worden und jetzt am
Wochenende während dieser Feuerpause kam
Emily frei und wurde hier wieder mit
ihrem Vater vereint und es gibt eben
diese Geschichten der Rückkehr natürlich
jetzt in Israel aber es gibt auch
Geschichten der Rückkehr im
Westjordanland wo inhaftierte
freigelassen werden drei Menschen drei
Gefangene für eine israelische Geisel
und darüber nun ein Bericht von Jonas
Kapp auf den Schultern tragen sie Khalil
Samar zu seiner Mutter eine Rückkehr die
im Westjordanland gefeiert wird die
meisten freigelassenen Häftlinge stammen
von hier meist verhaftet wegen
Steinwürfen oder ähnlichen vergehen oft
auch ohne Verfahren Gaza Stadt eine
einsame Rückkehr die Feuerpause hat Ali
machdi die Gelegenheit gegeben nach
Hause zu gehen seinen Vater und Neffen
hat er dort tot
aufgefunden genau hier haben mein
kleiner Bruder und ich ein Grab
ausgehoben und die beiden
beerdigt
in Gaza Stadt steht fast kein Stein mehr
auf dem anderen die Stadt ist schwer
gezeichnet von Luftangriffen israel will
dass sich über 2 Millionen Menschen an
diesem kleinen Streifen im Süden
aufhalten in
almawasi dort würde internationale
humanitäre Hilfe zugelassen heißt es
schon hier in Gasa Stadt lebten die
Menschen dicht an dicht wieo viele in
der humanitären Zone unterkommen sollen
ist unklar und so bleibt die
Ungewissheit wie es nach der Feuerpause
weiter gehen
soll bei uns nun live mit Einschätzung
vor Ort aus Israel unser Korrespondent
Michael bwerung in Tel Aviv hallo schön
guten
Abend hallo Michael wir haben gerade im
Beitrag ein Beispiel gehört ein Beispiel
von einem Inhaftierten Palästinenser der
eben jetzt aus dem Gefängnis entlassen
wurde das wird gefeiert von vielen
Menschen im Westjordanland kann man
sagen dass das der ham Hamas nützt weil
eben dort jetzt vielleicht Dankbarkeit
zeigt wird für diese freigelassenen
Inhaftierten also ich würde es so
formulieren die Hamas versucht zumindest
das so zu
instrumentalisieren dass das als ihr
Erfolg dargestellt wird ich glaube das
ist so ein gemischtes Bild natürlich
rechnet man das der Hamas an man sieht
dann teilweise auch die Grünen Flaggen
bei den Freilassung der Hamas aber ich
glaube die werden schnell gereicht von
bestimmten Hamas Funktionären also äh
die Freude ist glaube ich eher ganz
ursprünglich bei den Menschen dass ihre
Angehörigen ihre Kinder wieder zu ihren
Familien zurückkehren
und die Hamas versucht natürlich das
auszuschlachten sicherlich kriegt sie
dafür auch einen gewissen Kredit aber
ich würde sagen grundsätzlich ist es
einfach so
dass der Hass der Palästinenser sowohl
in Westjordanland als auch in Gaza auf
Israel einfach viel größer ist als auch
als die Wut auf die Hamas natürlich äh
wird ja ma von vielen auch unterstützt
aber von vielen wird sie auch kritisch
gesehen aber was man vielleicht als
Vergleich heranziehen kann beim letzten
großen Krieg vor zwei Jahren gab es hier
in Israel massive Auseinandersetzung mit
palästinensischen Israelis und jüdischen
Israelis das haben wir in diesem ganzen
Krieg noch nicht gesehen es gab auch
keinen größeren Aufstand im westjordland
es gab keine größeren Unruhen in
Ostjerusalem daran kann man vielleicht
ermessen dass die große Solidar mit der
Hamas in diesem Krieg bisher
ausgeblieben ist angesprochenen Beitrag
war eben auch an eine noch etwas andere
Rückkehr die Rückkehr von Menschen in
Gaza die jetzt trotz der Warnung der
israelischen Armee sich in den Norden
aufmachen schauen was übrig ist von
ihrem Leben schauen auch nach natürlich
Menschen ihren Menschen ihren nächsten
ob sie gestorben sind wenn sie da jetzt
vorfinden nur Trümmer und Tod was macht
das denn mit dem Rückhalt für Hamas in
Gaza also ich ich würde auch da
differenzieren was es genau macht kann
ich natürlich auch nicht beurteilen wir
haben leider nach wie vor eigentlich gar
keinen Zugang zu Gaser aber wir sprechen
halt immer über unsere producer die in
Gaser mit den Menschen sprechen und das
Bild was wir da hören ist differenziert
einerseits natürlich
Solidarisierung mit der herras man kann
das auch so an kleinen
Ereignissen beurteilen eine Geisel z.B
der die jetzt gerade freigekommen ist B
gestern der ist es gelungen für drei
Tage zu flüchten am Ende hat die
Bevölkerung der Geisel nicht etwa
geholfen sondern hat sie zurück zur
Hamas gebracht dann sieht man schon dass
einfach na ja ein Verhältnis der
Unterwürfigkeit der
zwangssolidärisierung da ist das heißt
die Menschen äh wissen halt dass die
Hamas die herrschende Kraft ist und
sicherlich wird ein großer Teil das
fanatisch unterstützen ein Teil
teilweise aber ein großer Teil das hören
wir auch immer wieder sehr sehr kritisch
weil die haben eben auch für diesen
Krieg und die damit verbundenen damit
verbundenen Zerstörungen verantwortlich
gemacht wird und nach zwei Monaten ist
eben endlich auch eine größere Zahl an
Geiseln nach Israel zurückgekehrt vor
allem Frauen und Kinder trotzdem immer
noch eine dreistellige Zahl an Geiseln
in der Gewalt der Hamas wie groß ist der
Druck auf die Regierung von Netanyahu
diese Feuerpause jetzt zu verlängern um
eben noch mehr Geiseln frei beekommen zu
können der ist natürlich enorm groß und
jeder mag sich nun mal vorstellen die
eigene Tochter der eigene Bruder der
eigene Vater Mutter wären da als Geiseln
da ist man natürlich bereit allem
zuzustimmen ob das strategisch richtig
ist eine andere Frage aber man kann die
Not der Menschen verstehen und das übt
einen enormen Druck auf die Regierung
aus jetzt deswegen ist es ja auch zuer
Feuerpause gekommen und die funktioniert
ja auch ganz gut und das Ziel wird
erreicht dass viel möglichst viele
Geiseln freikommen wie
viele wird man am Ende sehen aber ich
fürchte es werden bei weitem nicht alle
Geiseln freikommen schon gar nicht die
Soldaten die gefangen sind darunter
übrigens auch mehrere weibliche
Soldaten die werden bis zum Schluss als
faustfand von der Hamas gehalten werden
irgendwann wird diese Waffenruhe enden
und dann das ist klar wird die Armee
wahrscheinlich diesen Kampf weiterführen
zum Schluss noch eine Frage aus dem
Stream an Dich von Bora B er oder sie
fragt wird Israel gelingen die Hamas
militärisch und politisch zu zerschlagen
das natürlich jetzt eine sehr
langfristige Frage ich würde auch noch
kurzfristig von mir gerne anschließen
wie nutzt denn auch Israel die die
Waffenpause solange sie gerade noch
hält also Israel Macht eines klar dass
es nur darauf wartet dass diese
Waffenpause zu Ende ist um die Hamas
vollständig zu zerschlagen und da kann
man dann anschließend wieder zerschlagen
militärisch und politisch politisch
würde ich mal sagen auf gar keinen Fall
Fall die Hamas ist politisch in den
ganzen Nachbarstaaten aufgestellt also
die politische Bewegung der Hamas wird
man nicht zerschlagen können aber was
sicherlich möglich ist ist die
militärische Struktur der Hamas zu
zerschlagen das sieht man jetzt im
Norden wie weit das gelingen kann das
wird auch im Süden möglich sein und die
Frage was passiert danach wie wird der
Gazastreifen dann aussehen weil die
Hamas als politische Kraft auf jeden
Fall da ist und die Frage ist ob die
Bevölkerung auch die Kraft die mentale
Kraft dazu sehen dass sie vielleicht
auch von dieser Diktatur befreit worden
ist der Hamas denn es ist eine Diktatur
und viele Menschen leiden auch darunter
eine korrupte Diktatur wo Hamas Führer
extreme Privilegien hatten das wird man
sehen müssen aber die die Absicht der
Armee ist ganz klar die zumindest die
militärischen Strukturen der Hamas
vollständig zu zerschlagen und danach
wird man sehen umgekehrt wie viel Kraft
bringt Israel auf vielleicht den
Menschen dort entgegenzukommen und
irgendetwas Neues da aufzubauen wo nicht
mehr die hamastas sagen kann und wo
vielleicht irgendwie eine sehr
bescheidene friedliche Vision aufkeimt
Einschätzung von Michael bwerunge live
aus Tel Aviv vielen Dank auch heute
wieder an Dich
Michael und bei uns ist jetzt wieder
militäranalyst Hendrik Remmel ist uns
jetzt wieder zugeschaltet und ich schaue
jetzt auch in eure Fragen ich habe
gesehen da ist einiges zusammengekommen
und Herr Remmel jetzt für uns natürlich
da um da einiges zu beantworten Chris
Wats sehe ich zunächst bei youtube hat
sich gefragt hat die Hamas in der
Feuerpause die Chance eine neue
Strategie mit hiszbollah abzustimmen
meint also damit die Hisbollah Miliz im
Süden vom Libanon also die Gefahr aus
dem Norden was würden Sie zu dieser
Frage
antworten das würde mit Sicherheit im
strategischen Interesse der Hamas liegen
die Kernfrage ist aber
sieht die hiszbollah und sieht vor allem
der Iran ähm eine strategische
Notwendigkeit darin und vor allem sehen
Sie einen strategischen Nutzen ich halte
es für eher unwahrscheinlich dass sich
die hisbolla in den Kampf zeitnah
einmischt denn wenn Sie ein Interesse
daran gehabt hätte dann hätte sie schon
längst
getan insbesondere der Iran verhält sich
aber abseits von der dem iranischen
Führungspersonal angeeigneten
islamistischen aggressiven Rhetorik
auffallen zurückhaltend
ich glaube nicht dass es im Interesse
des Irans liegt diesen Konflikt
eskalieren zu lassen deswegen kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass die Hisbollah
im
Zeitnahmen in zeitnah Zukunft aus dem
Libanon die israelischen Streitkräfte
angreift zumal die israelischen
Streitkräfte im Norden Israels auch sehr
sehr gut aufgestellt sind und für genau
diesen Fall vorbereitet sind gehen wir
auch mal mehr auf die Militärstrategie
ein und schauen uns da auch zunächst mal
ein paar Bilder an wie es aktuell in
Gaza aussieht Journalistinnen und
Journalisten von AP ist es gelungen eben
nach Gaza zu gehen zeigen hier hier nun
ein Bild aus bet nun der Zerstörung da
steht nicht mehr viel viele Häuser eben
die zerstört sind und jetzt muss man
sich natürlich fragen angesichts solcher
Zerstörung aus Gaza die man aus dem
Norden von Gaza in den letzten Wochen
gesehen hat wie sieht es da um die
Infrastruktur wie ist es da bestellt um
die Infrastruktur der Hamas wurde da
jetzt nicht auch massiv zerstört schon
in den letzten Wochen was ist da
überhaupt noch
übrig der urbane Raum des
gaserastreifens zeichnet sich außer
massig besonders dadurch aus dass es ein
weit verzweigtes Tunnelsystem gibt im
militärischen Kontext spricht man nicht
umsst von dem sogenannten urban Warfare
also dem Kampf im urbanen Raum und dem
suburban Warfare den Kampf
unterurbanenraum in seiner Komplexität
und seiner weitreichenden Struktur ist
das Tunnelsystem unter dem gaserstreifen
einzigartig das heißt die Hamas sind
vermutlich in der Lage dre bis vi Monate
vollkommen AAG in diesem Tunnelsystem zu
leben sie haben genug was sie haben
genug Treibstoff sie haben genug
Verpflegung sie haben genug Munition das
heißt sie sind durchaus in der Lage sich
diesem massiven
Feuer dieser Initiative dieser
Initiativen Operationen der israelischen
streiträfte zu entziehen und in der
weiteren Folge dann sich durch die
Tunnelsysteme sowohl defensiv als auch
offensiv zu bewegen das heißt Sie können
auch vermeintlich genommenes Gelände von
israelischen Streitkräften durch die
Tunnelsysteme wieder betreten und die
israelischen Streitkräfte im Rücken
angreifen
das wissen die israelischen Streitkräfte
natürlich aber brauchen oben diese Räume
zu sichern und die weiter vorenden
Truppen zu sichern extrem hohe
kräfteansätze sie müssen sich vorstellen
dass sie jeden Durchbruch jeden
Tunneleingang den sie noch nicht
geflutet oder zu betoniert oder
freigekämpft haben mit eigenen Kräften
überwachen müssen das ist eine ein
enormer Kräfteansatz der für die
israelischen Streitkräfte hier von Nöten
ist das heißt die Infrastruktur als
solches die sie übererdisch überirdisch
sehen spielt nur eine bedingte Rolle und
deswegen trügt auch ein wenig dieser
kartenblick indem man dann feststellen
kann ja die israelischen Streitkräfte
haben signifikante Raumgewinne erzielt
aber die israelischen Streitkräfte
führen ein sogenannten
kräfteorientierten Angriff durch das
heißt sie suchen oder ihr Angriffsziel
liegt in den Hamas Strukturen und vor
allem in dem Personal der Hamas nicht in
einem raumorientierten Angriff hier muss
man sehr vorsichtig sein und darf die
Raum gewinnen Erfolge der israelischen
streiträfte noch nicht zu hoch
einschätzen genauso eine Karte mit dem
was Sie beschrieben haben haben wir
gerade gesehen eine Karte des Institutes
for the study of war das was sie jetzt
aber gerade beschrieben haben also dass
Hamas nach wie vor die Tunnel nutzen
kann sich also Operationen dadurch
entziehen kann dadurch auch Gelände
wieder betreten kann was vielleicht
zuvor genommen war das klingt ja schon
danach dass diese Feuerpause jetzt auch
eine Möglichkeit schafft für die Hamas
oder
in dem Raum des nördlichen
gaserstreifens ins besondere gaserstadt
auf jeden Fall ich habe die Karte jetzt
Leber selber leider nicht gesehen ich
gehe aber davon aus dass sie zeigen wird
dass die israelischen Streitkräfte zum
einen den nördlichen Teil des
Gazastreifens mit israelischen
Streitkräften von
Osten nach Westen abgeschnitten haben
das heißt sie sind bis zur Küste
vorgedrungen und sie sind vor allem im
Zuge des Küstenstreifens von der
nördlichen Grenze des
gaserstreifens Richtung Süden zum
alschiverkrank ausfororgedrogen das
haben sie mit jeweils einer Division
gemacht das heißt sie haben im Grunde
genommen eine sogenannte operative
Einschließung vollzogen die hamaskämpfer
können also überirdisch nirgendwo mehr
hin sie können nicht einfach so nach
Süden ausweichen
jetzt kann man natürlich das Argument
bringen sie können ja Tunnelsysteme
nutzen die von Norden nach Süden führen
aber auch hierfür haben die israelischen
Streitkräfte natürlich technische
Voraussetzung
südlich des von Gasa Stadt wird das
Gelände etwas durchschnittener das heißt
es wird weniger stark bebaut das ist
kein urbaner Ballungsraum mehr hier
können Sie mit technischen Mitteln also
unterirdische Tunnelsysteme aufklären
und gegebenenfalls zerstören das
bedeutet die israelischen die Hamas kann
nicht einfach so sich von Nord nach Süd
bewegen oder sich frei im Raum bewegen
ähm das bedeutet sie sind eingekreist
und ihre Handlungsoption was die Räume
angeht sind sehr gering und beschränken
sich im Grunde genommen auf das
Ballungszentrum in gazaastadt und dass
die israelischen Streitkräfte bis dato
noch nicht vorgedrungen sind wir haben
ein paar Kommentare im Stream wir
diskutieren ja auch heute es haben wir
mit unser Überschrift der Sendung ja
auch klar gemacht wie wie die Situation
die der Erfolg der Heras zurzeit
aussieht möchte ein paar Kommentare
jetzt hier in unser Gespräch auch
einbringen z.B schreibt Markus bei
Youtube Hamas hat hier
massiv propagandistisch haayay gewonnen
das er rein militärisch zu sehen meines
Erachtens kurzsichtig kurz merken darauf
würde ich gerne noch eingehen und dann
hier noch ein weiterer Kommentar der
kommt von einem User wo ist er mir jetzt
hingerutscht genau hier oben
mit einem kürzelnen der schreibt Israel
führte unter netanahus Führung drei
großangelegte Militäroperationen im
Gazastreifen durch und zwar 2012 14 und
2021 all diese Operationen endeten
schließlich mit einem Gewinn der Hamas
wie würden Sie diese Kommentare
einschätzen und
einordnen den ersten Kommentar kann ich
glaube ich genauso unterschreiben wie er
reingestellt worden ist die Hamas hat
wenn wir uns das geostrategische
Gesamtbild angucken den Kampf um die
deut so Halit in diesen Konflikt
durchaus gewonnen das sehen wir an einer
UN-Resolution die Israel mit einer
relativ großen Mehrheit zur Einstellung
der Kampfhandlung aufgerufen hat das
sehen wir bei der Berichterstattung die
sich außerhalb der westlichen Medien
darstellt und durchaus ein anderes Bild
dieses Konfliktes zeichnet und gewisse
narrative bedient die die Hamas schon
seit ihrer Gründung anführt warum Israel
im Jihad bekämpft werden muss
m ich will das nicht einordnen und sagen
was ist richtig und was ist falsch ähm
für mich als Analyst ist relevant wer
gerade den die deutungshohheit in einer
geostrategischen Machtkonstellation hat
und da kann ich durchaus sagen den hat
die Hamas und allgemein die
unterstützerstaaten der Hamas durchaus
gewonnen Israels in der
Staatengemeinschaft verhältnismäßig
isoliert
ähm könnten sie noch mal auf die zweite
Frage bitte eingehen absolut wenn ich
sie noch mal finden würde da würde ich
kurz meine Kollegin bitten die noch mal
rauszusuchen die holen wir wieder auf
wieder vor Lage versprochen würde jetzt
eine noch dazwischen stellen und zwar
von Tobias kompfe bei Youtube der fragt
sich wie sollte die Hamas militärisch
besser bekämpft werden mit weniger
zivilen Opfern wenn die militärische
Infrastruktur der Hamas genau dort
liegt mir ist die Frage wieder
eingefallen die kann ich gleich zusammen
beantworten also ja israel hat in den
letzten Jahren durchaus die eine oder
andere Militäroperation durchgeführt die
letzte Besetzung des gazre liegt aber
allerdings
gut 15 mehr als 15 Jahre zurück das
letzte Mal 2005 die letzten
Militäroperationen der israelischen
streiträfte haben sich Primer darauf
konzentriert die Tunnelsysteme der Hamas
zu zerstören und vor allem dort die
Tunnelsysteme zu zerstören die auf
israelische Staatsgebiet gehen
das bedeutet dass die israelischen
Streitkräfte eine großangelegte
Offensive mit einem Vorstoß in das
Ballungszentrum von gazastadt seit
langer Zeit nicht unternommen haben
und anhand dieser Skalierung kann man
auch feststellen war eine offensive eine
militärische Offensive der israelischen
Streitkräfte erfolgreich oder nicht das
kann man so und so sehen wichtig ist
aber dass sich ein militärischer Erfolg
gerade in einer asymmetrischen
Kriegsführung immer in einem
gesamtstrategischen Kontext betrachtet
wird und dass die Frage ob Sieg oder
Niederlage immer eine politische ist und
immer eine Frage der narrative denn das
ist auch im Grunde genommen das
Hauptproblem der Israelis gerade
Militärs können in einem asymmetrischen
t grundsätzlich nur Voraussetzungen
schaffen um politische Entwicklung in
die eine oder andere Richtung zu
schaffen das heißt die Frage ist eine
eine solche Militäroperation langfristig
erfolgreich also welches strategisches
endstate Szenario wir haben ist eine
politische und da hat Israel bis jetzt
noch keine befriedigende Lösung gefunden
und auch die Weltgemeinschaft hat keine
befriedigende Lösung angeboten wie der
gaserastreifen in naher Zukunft
befriedet werden kann das wird alleine
das Militär nicht können auch wenn die
Hamas Strukturen in militärischer
Dimension zerstört werden können die
Ideologie der Hamas können Sie mit
israelischen Streitkräften nicht
zerstören so ich meine ich habe die
Frage wieder gefunden also ja nee aber
sie sagten ja sowieso siener Danes guten
gedächtnises ja genau die zweite die
Weite Frage war glaube ich das mit der
Infrastruktur und den
Hamas bzw den palästinensischen Opfern
richtig wie die besser geschützt werden
können jedes Opfer genau jedes Opfer im
Krieg ist eine Katastrophe jedes m man
muss aber und jetzt geht es nicht um
Relativierung sondern um
Kontextualisierung einordnen dass die
Hamas natürlich ein militärstrategisches
Kalkül verfolgt und erhebliche Teile der
Infrastruktur im gaserstreifen nutzt um
einen militärischen Effekt zu erzielen
gemessen an
dieser Strategie die sie nie ganz
ausschalten können vor allem in einer
asymmetrischen Kriegs
sind die Opfer die die israelischen
Streitkräfte
zweifelsohne produziert haben
verhältnismäßig gering bei ungefähr 2
Millionen Palästinensern im Gazastreifen
davon einem relativ erheblich großer
Anteil im Norden von
Gasastreifen sind 10 11 oder 12000
Zivilisten getötet worden das ist
unermesslich viel und jedes einzelne
zivile Opfer ist eins zu viel aber das
ist eine absoluter promillbereich an
zivilen Opfern den sie in anderen
Kriegen in viel viel höheren Zahlen
finden wir reden also von
0,05 bis
0,078% ziviler Opfer die die
israelischen Streitkräfte in einem der
am dichtesten besiedelten
urbanen Räume dieser Welt produziert
haben gegen einen Gegner der bewusst
diese zivilen Kräfte einsetzt das heißt
man kann durchaus argumentieren auch
wenn das Endergebnis ein furchtbares ist
dass die israelischen Streitkräfte
durchaus ein Interesse und hung zeigen
diese zivilen Opfer zu minimieren können
sie es noch mehr ich glaube nicht die
israelischen Streitkräfte sind dort
perfederweise durch die letzten Einsätze
im gaserstreifen schon sehr gut geübt
sie haben immer Rechtsberater in jeder
Einheit die analysieren und
sicherstellen kann ich dieses Gebäude
jetzt bombardieren beschießen was auch
immer es ist ein völkerrechtlich
legitimeses militärisches Ziel auf der
anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch
sagen dass in jedem Konflikt von jeder
Armee immer Fehler gemacht werden und
das Menschen immer
zu Unrecht zu Schaden kommen und Sterben
das muss man in dieser Einordnung auch
ganz klar sagen eine desaströse Lage für
die Zivilisten in Gaza natürlich auch in
den letzten zwei Monaten und schauen wir
mal gemeinsam auf eine Karte die die
israelische Armee veröffentlicht hat in
dieser Karte kann man sehen wenn es eben
nach Israel geht dass diese über 2
Millionen Menschen in Gaza sich in
diesem kleinen Streifen hier im Süden
aufhalten sollen in almawasi dort würde
so heißt es internationale humanitäre
Hilfe zugelassen jetzt sehen wir hier
natürlich auch in der Skalierung dass es
ein sehr sehr kleiner Streifen ist den
man hier sieht also worauf müssen wir
uns einstellen jetzt auch im Bezug auf
die Situation für Zivilisten in Gaza
nach der Feuerpause wenn es die nicht
mehr
gibt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass die Zivilbevölkerung die
palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung
nördlich der von den israelischen
Streitkräften eingeschlossenen Grenze
wenn man so will weiter notleiden wird
die israelischen Streitkräfte werden ähm
ihre Militäroperation fortsetzen und die
Menschen die im Gazastreifen im
nördlichen Teil bleiben werden weiter
notleiden es werden weiter Zivilisten
sterben
ähm ich vermute aber ich kann es nicht
mit absoluter Sicherheit sagen dass die
israelischen Streitkräfte kein
signifikantes Interesse daran haben auch
an den bodenoffensiv im südlichen Teil
durchzuführen das liegt daran dass die
meisten der 15 bis 30.000 hamaskämpfer
vermutlich im Ballungszentrum von Gaza
Stadt sind das liegt daran dass die
urbanen Strukturen in den
Ballungszentren da wo die israelischen
Streitkräfte auch noch nicht
vorgedrungen sind für den vorgesehenen
Kampf der Hammers am günstigsten sind
das Gelände im Süden des Gazastreifens
ist etwas weitläufiger dort können die
israelischen Streitkräfte ihre
technischen Vorteile ausspielen sie
können Panzer einsetzen so wie es jetzt
auch schon getan haben es gibt aber
Bereiche im Nord Norden gasas in gas
Stadt wo sie diese Panzer nicht mehr
einsetzen können weil die Straßenzüge
schlicht untergreifend zu schmal werden
das heißt dort kommt es dann in der Tat
zu einem Kampf der Infanterie im
klassischen Orts und Häuserkampf und
dort können die hamaskämpfer den
israelischen Streitkräften großen
Schaden zufügen das heißt aus rein
militärischen
Gesichtspunkten muss man jetzt nicht
befürchten dass in den nächsten Tagen
die israelischen Streitkräfte auch in
den Süden vordringen und dort die Hamas
bekämpfen weil sie dort schlicht und
ergreifend keine lohnenswerten Ziele
sehen
wie sich die humanitäre Situation dann
im Süden Grenzübergang darstellen wird
kann ich nicht beurteilen ich kann nicht
in die Glaskugel schauen
man muss aber durchaus in diesem Kontext
erwähnen dass natürlich der
Grenzübergang im Süden von Ägypten
kontrolliert wird das heißt zu einem
nicht unerheblichen Anteil entscheidet
Ägypten darüber ob
diese mehrere Millionen also knapp 2
Millionen wahrscheinlich sind es eher
1,5 Millionen Palästinenser den
Gazastreifen Richtung Ägypten verlassen
können derzeit scheint es kein
signifikantes Interesse dafür zu geben
sie sagen darüber entscheidet Ägypten
natürlich über diesen Grenzübergang und
wen Ägypten da auch drüber lässt wer
jetzt aber auch eine entscheidende Rolle
gespielt hat als Vermittler war Qatar
und dazu jetzt bezüglich dieser
Verhandlungen eben und was da vielleicht
auch in den nächsten Wochen noch möglich
ist oder auch nicht gibt's noch eine
Frage aus dem Stream an sie bei youtube
hat Qatar so viel Macht über die Hamas
ich nehme an die Frage impliziert so
viel Macht um sie eben immer wieder dazu
bewegen auch
irgendwelche ja irgendwelche wie nennt
man es am besten ein Deal wäre ein
falsches Wort auf jeden Fall aber so
etwas einzugehen einzuwilligen zu einer
Feuerpause dazu Geiseln freizulassen und
so
weiter eine sehr gute Frage die ich
gerne noch in einen geostrategischen
Kontext einrollen
möchte die westliche Welt muss zur
kennnis nehmen dass sich in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten gewisse
Machtstrukturen einer bipolaren bzw dann
unipolaren Weltordnung verschoben haben
es gibt Akteure gerade in dieser Region
nach dem Abzug der US-Truppen die ein
gewisses Machtvakuum auf diplomatischer
oder militärischer Bühne ausgenutzt
haben dazu gehört der Iran dazu gehört
Saudi-Arabien der zugehört aber auch
Qatar Qatar spielt in der ich nenne es
mal vereinfachen gesagt arabischen Welt
eine signifikante Rolle sie hab ein sehr
hohen Stellenwert das liegt unter
anderem daran dass sie eine sehr potente
Finanzwirtschaft haben und es ist nicht
das erste Mal dass Qatar eine
diplomatische schwergewichtsrolle
gespielt hat erinnern wir uns an die
über an die Evakuierung äh in Kabul in
Afghanistan wo unter anderem zahlreiche
Flüchtlingsströme und die das Ausfliegen
von zivilpersonal vom kabula Flughafen
durch eine Verhandlungslösung mit den
Taliban von Qatar erwirkt worden ist das
heißt wir müssen uns in Zukunft auch
darauf einstellen dass es nicht mehr nur
die USA sind oder nur der Westen ist der
eine diplomatische Lösung herbeiführt
sondern dass es viele verschiedene
Akteure sind auf der Welt in vielen
verschiedenen Regionen und für die
arabische Welt wird Qatar auch in
Zukunft eine solche diplomatische Rolle
spielen so viele verschiedene Akteure
die da was zu sagen haben wenn Sie das
sagen können Sie vielleicht das ist für
uns eine Zukunftsfrage die ist schwer zu
beantworten aber sagen was das bedeuten
würde ist ein Waffenstillstand in
Zukunft komplett ausgeschlossen ist
sowas auch nur ansatzweise realistisch
können Sie dazu uns noch eine Aussage
geben der israelische
Verteidigungsminister hat vor einem
wenig Tagen angedeutet dass die
Militäroperation noch mindestens zwei
Monate dauern wird wenn es das Ziel ist
sämtliche ähm hamasstrukturen im Norden
vom Gazastreifen militärisch zu
zerstören dann teile ich diese
Einschätzung
anschließend und das ist die
grundlegende strategische Frage die sich
Israel aber auch die Weltgemeinschaft
stellen muss was passiert danach was ist
das endstate Szenario wenn die
Kampfhandlung eingestellt sind wenn es
schlicht unergreifend keine
militärischen Ziele mehr gibt denn
grundlegend die strategischen Ziele die
israel hatte nämlich einmal die
Etablierung reetablierung einer
glaubhaften abschreckungslogik nach
außen also dem zeigen der Akteure
insbesondere des Irans wenn ihr uns
militärisch angreifft wird das
erhebliche Konsequenzen haben aber auch
die Wiederherstellung eines inneren
Sicherheitsgefühls also ein nach innen
gerichtetes strategisches Ziel für die
israelische Bevölkerung kann nur
sichergestellt werden wenn es eine
nachhaltige Befriedung des gasastreifens
gibt derzeit gibt es kein Akteur kein
strategischen Akteur weder die UN noch
ein einzelner Akteur der bereit ist sich
in diese Richtung zu verpflichten und
den Gazastreifen beispielsweise durch
eine Friedenstruppe zu
stabilisieren das heißt grundsätzlich
aus rein militärischen Gesichtspunkten
wird sich dieses Fenster für einen
Waffenstillstand öffnen die
entscheidende und strategische Frage ist
aber werden die durch das durch das
Militär geschaffenen Voraussetzung
genutzt um eine für alle Parteien
befriedende Lösung herbeizuführen daran
habe ich gegenwärtig meine Zweifel sagt
militäranalyst Hendrik Remmel vielen
Dank dass Sie heute sich so viel Zeit
genommen haben und unser Gast
waren sehr gerne und während wir hier
eine gute halbe Stunde miteinander
gesprochen haben hat sich auch der UN
Generalsekretär guterisch gemeldet das
möchte ich gerne hier zum Schluss noch
sagen er ihm zufolge er sagte es würde
nicht ausreichen die verlängerte
Feuerpause um die benötigte Hilfe den
Gasastreifen zu bringen es sei Zitat
dramatisch was die Bevölkerung dort
benötige und er hat eben Hoffnung
guterrisch dass weitere Grenzübergänge
geöffnet werden könnten wir haben es ja
auch gerade gehört von Herrn Remmel nur
der Grenzübergang rafar zu Ägypten ist
eben der der genutzt werden kann und
guterisch so weiter dies würde es auch
für Israel einfacher machen die
Lieferungen zu kontrollieren die
reingehen gegenwärtig ist eben nur der
Grenzübergang zu Raffa geöffnet wir
bleiben natürlich für euch weiter ganz
aktuell mit Meldung darüber bei ztf
heute für euch den ganzen Abend über
seid ihr da informiert wir bleiben da
für euch dran für heute für jetzt für
den Moment erstmal vielen Dank und bis
zum nächsten Mal
tschüss